thank you to the academy for this
incredible honor my biggest thank you
goes to the wonderful collective of
creatives that came together in making
this film to my producers esther bush
philip rauber jude kawa and gabrielle
walt vogel
to the amazing heads of departments and
crew to our rising little star aisha
balasim and the talented ziad bakri and
khaled tarifi
i would like as well to thank my film
school film academy baden wittenberg in
germany and its director professor
thomas chad for believing in us and the
story that we're telling
thank you to the royal film commission
for believing in me personally and
supporting my career
thank you to esv
lang
to
jordan pioneers with the ceo khalid
haddad
taba 360 to box elder entertainment to
my mother family and friends and
everyone who supported us in the making
of this film
our film is about
childhood and war zones it's about this
vicious cycle of broken dreams
i hope one day this cycle is broken
allowing dreams and innocence
to prevail again thank you